i have an amazing circle around me
my circle of friends are amazing
they have never left me
nene leakes thanks her celebrity pals
for helping her grieve the death of her
late husband greg
on friday the real housewives of atlanta
star opened up on her insta story about
all the support she has received since
her husband lost his battle with colon
cancer earlier this month nene gave a
special shout out to lauren london who
unexpectedly lost her longtime love
nipsey hustle back in 2019.
thank you to lauren london you have
reached out to me so many times and you
know to help me
go through
this process as you have gone through it
thank you
and she went on sending her gratitude to
a long list of her close celebrity
friends
thank you to all the real housewives of
atlanta first chrissy teigen and john
legend patti labelle khadijah and her
twin sister
the ladies at the real i just bumped
into t.i and tiny a couple days ago tiny
is always super sweet and
thank you for all of your kind words
i've had so many amazing phone calls and
amazing text messages that just keep
pouring in and pouring it and pouring in
uh yolanda adams thank you tamar braxton
that's forever in my ear
thank you anthony anderson
thank you the 53 year old reality star
also thanked her fans for their love
support and dms
thank you to all of you uh that are in
my dms
[Laughter]
that has been
fun and hilarious to uh
to look at the love has been
amazing i mean every morning when i wake
up i have a ton of text messages telling
me to be encouraged y'all already know
i'm
you know i i'm definitely human but you
know i'm strong and i i'm strong in my
faith this all comes after the tv
personality opened up about her grief on
instagram thursday i have good days and
bad days now that i'm having to adjust
to my
new life my new normal
pushing through
pushing through
and nene shared details about her
support system at home i have a whole
group of people that's coming to my
house every day doing different stuff
with me so trying to keep my mind off of
you know
the events that recently happened love
you guys okay and um
i'm pushing through
greg died on september 1st at the age of
66. i would just like to say i love you
so much
a celebration of life was held in
atlanta last week where several of her
former bravo castmates got together to
pay their respects among those in
attendance lisa wu phaedra parks marlow
hampton portia williams eva marcel and
kenya moore honestly he is one of the
nicest men i've ever met in my life to
be there was a no-brainer and when it
caught up with kenya last week she
opened up about the touching service
he was just a kind gentle
caring supportive man and she was really
lucky to have him i think it was
everything she probably wanted it to be
because people were happy and i think he
would have wanted people to be happy
because his life was so full and so
beautiful and he was such a great person
it seemed like she she got what she
wanted for people to smile and and i
think he would have been happy about
that